[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas noches estoy muy feliz de estar
aquí con ustedes en esta noche y les voy
a hablar un poco sobre mi vida y quiero
empezar con esta fotografía que tiene
ustedes aquí que yo pienso que fue el
algo que completamente cambió mi curso
de vida fue el 85 en ese tiempo mi madre
era una madre soltera yo era la mayor de
cuatro hijos y cuando esto ocurrió
cambió completamente nuestra vida aquí
en el distrito federal ella decidió que
lo mejor para nosotros era podernos ir a
los eeuu crecer en los eeuu así es que
me acuerdo vivamente al llegar de la
de la escuela y mi mamá nos dijo nos
vamos mañana y agarro dos maletas y las
lleno de las cosas más importantes que
ella creía que era de nosotros cinco y
nos fuimos al siguiente día
yo la verdad era una niña de 14 años y
yo pensé que algún día iba a regresar a
mexico muy pronto no me la creía que nos
iban a llevar a los eeuu nos íbamos a
quedar allá
pero no tuvimos que dejar todo deje a mi
familia a mis amigos a todo lo que yo
tenía que conocía
durante ese tiempo y llegamos a los eeuu
en san jose california
ahí fue una mamá se quedó y empezamos
una nueva vida fue una nueva historia
para nosotros empezar nuestro hogar ahí
tuve que aprender el idioma las
costumbres crear nuevos amigos
y fue el difícil al principio pero sin
embargo no lo sé lo seguía porque era la
vida que yo aunque nosotros teníamos
entonces cuando yo llegué a san josé
fui a una escuela preparatoria y me
acuerdo que me iba a graduar y estaba
cumpliendo 18 años y mi mamá me dijo lee
tienes que ayudarme a mantener la casa
porque no voy a poder yo no puedo yo
sola llegando son 4 niños entonces la
mayor base tiendes a cumplir 18 años
tienes me puedes ayudar y empecé a
trabajar antes de terminar mi
preparatoria y al poco tiempo de eso mi
mamá perdió el trabajo y me quedé yo
como responsable de la carga económica
en mi casa entonces fue difícil porque
tuve que trabajar y estudiar y quería yo
sabía que quería ir a la universidad
quería empezar la carrera entonces yo
esperaba poder graduarme de la prepa ir
a la universidad de nuestros oídos y
pasa que pasa una ley antiinmigrante de
las 187 en ese tiempo
y se me dificultó ir a la universidad
entonces no pude ir pero pude ir a un
colegio que éste se absorbe que también
es el colegio de san josé este el sanse
city college y empecé a ir a la escuela
pero como se puede imaginar una persona
tan joven de 18 19 años haber tenido la
experiencia del terremoto en 1985 donde
perdí amigos y familiares haber tenido
que emigrar a otro país aprender el
lenguaje tener la responsabilidad de
niños sobresalir sobresale sacar a mi
familia
obviamente fue muy difícil para mí y
tuve que dejar la escuela y en ese
momento para mí no fue tan difícil
porque me sentí
tenía depresión porque no me sentía que
iba a llegar a mis metas yo sabía que me
sentía un fracaso no podía seguir porque
sin embargo he ido me enfoqué en ir a
trabajar y poder ayudar a mi mamá y mis
hermanos con el paso del tiempo conozco
a alguien y tengo empecé a tener hijos
tengo cuatro hijos
cuando mi hija la menor tenía un año a
mis dos hijos en medio los denostan con
problemas mentales entonces tuve que
entonces yo ser como la madre tenerme
que educar sobre sus dificultades y
balas a las bibliotecas educar me
enfrentaba a los doctores que era lo que
tenían como los podía ayudar y en uno de
mis tantos
educaciones y buscadas como mejorar sus
habilidades me di cuenta que yo como
padre tenía que tener una carrera no que
tenía que tener una educación para
poderles darle una estabilidad porque
hijos como lo mis hijos tenían tres
estadísticas en la vida una era que iba
a terminar siendo drogadictos se iban a
morir jóvenes o iban a terminar
encarcelados y ninguna de esas tres
cosas yo quería para ellos yo quería que
fueran exitosos en la vida entonces en
ese momento decidí hacerme un plan de
cinco años y empecé a trabajar por un
año junte dinero y me regresé a la
escuela regresé al colegio dos años y
medio para poder terminar una carrera y
transferir me alzamos este
cuando estaba en san jose state
me preguntaban qué carrera quería yo
hacer y entre todas las carreras que
ellos tenían en la lista tenían se llama
ingeniería aeroespacial y esa carrera yo
inmediatamente cuando la vi todos mis
ojos se me pusieron nes snes de cerebros
y yo dije de ahí yo soy yo quiero ser
ingeniero espacial porque me acordé que
cuando yo era niña aquí en méxico mi
mamá que solamente tenía sexto grado de
educación ella compraba libros venía un
señor nos tocaba la puerta y me coloque
mamá le compraba libros cada semana el
señor ya sabía que mamá le iba a comprar
el libro entonces yo llegaba de la
escuela y me sentaba en el sillón de mi
casa y me ponía al haber ese libro el
libro que sea en aquel tiempo no había
internet no había una televisión todo el
tiempo no había teléfonos y para mí
leer los libros será mi pasión y tenían
esa fotografía que ustedes ven aquí es
un especial es el vehículo que lleva
manos al espacio americano
y cuando yo lo vi me cautivó porque iba
a llevar gente al espacio entonces yo
quería saber quiénes eran los que lo
diseñaron quién es qué es lo que
estudiaban vieron los ingenieros
aeroespaciales y en ese momento a los 7
años yo ya sabía que quería ser un
ingeniero espacial
entonces en san jose california a mis
treinta y tantos años yo decidí en ese
momento que iba a estudiar esa carrera y
en el transcurso de mi educación me
quedé como madre soltera y no teniendo
que cuidar a mis hijos pero nunca me di
por vencida sabía que yo tenía que
agarrar ese diploma para poderles dar un
mejor vida a ellos y bienestar
y les puedo decir un poco sobre lo que
hacía en los puede ser un poco solo que
sea nasa porque empecé a trabajar en
casa después de que me gradué en san
jose state
pero les puedo decir que muchas de las
tecnologías que nosotros hacemos
a lo que queremos y no hacer para llegar
al
a las galaxias y una bajo peter a marte
las tenemos que desarrollar y
tenemos que tener un equipo que sea
multidisciplinario
y como somos exploradores de la exploró
es por naturaleza y nos gusta saber que
hay más de nuestros de nuestro cielo
pero es difícil en estamos desarrollar
tecnología para poder tener mantener ese
cuerpo humano en el espacio para poder
mandar al humano a vivir en nuestros
lugares
tenemos que desarrollar tecnología única
y tenemos que
invertir en nuestra nuestra en nuestra
gente
en nuestras personas
de que bastante en la escuela más que
ahora nuestra tenemos muchas compañías
privadas que invierten en tecnología
para el espacio
y con el tiempo las universidades de la
escuelas pueden hacer productos
espaciales prácticamente
que está en el acceso de sus manos no
podemos ir al internet y obtener
información y construirlos
si alguien quiere hacerlo cualquier niño
puede tener ese acceso y ahorita yo
cuando estaba creciendo no lo tenía
entonces
cualquier persona ahorita puede hacer un
pequeño satélite un club s´arc como el
que pueden ver aquí
y desarrollarlo y esa tecnología nos da
la oportunidad de poder a desarrollar
desarrollarse tecnología que podamos
llevar al ser humano o establecernos en
la luna o en marte
un ejemplo de ello les voy a decir sobre
estos dos estudiantes que están en san
jose espero que estuviera lanzamos este
ellos dos
tenían una idea sobre hacer un
un prototipo sobre
virtual la realidad virtual
y porque la realidad virtual es algo tan
interesante porque nos da la oportunidad
de utilizarla en el espacio obviamente
si ustedes han tenido la experiencia
aquí pueden tener unos vagos que pueden
ver algo que se parece casi a que está
aquí enfrente verdad pero no está
entonces si nosotros podemos arrollar
esa misma tecnología y aplicarla al
espacio podemos resolver un montón de
problemas uno de ellos después de decir
en la estación espacial que está entre
300 kilómetros de altura dándole órbita
a la tierra muchas veces es dañada por
pequeños objetos que viajan súper
rápidamente y tenemos que sacar un
astronauta que revise dónde fue el daño
y obviamente un astronauta se hace son
ahora son como 68 horas para poder hacer
un
un viaje afuera de la estación espacial
entonces imagínense salirse de su
ambiente y tener que ir a un lugar donde
es muy difícil sobrevivir pero si
nosotros tenemos un pequeño satélite que
puede salir de la estación espacial y
darle la vuelta a la estación espacial
para ver dónde fue dañado y poderlo ver
desde aquí de la tierra o adentro de la
estación espacial y poder identificar
cuál fue el daño y cómo lo podemos
reparar podríamos hacerlos solucionar
ese problema pero también podemos
utilizarlo cuando hay otros satélites
que están incluso están más lejos de la
estación espacial que tienen problemas y
podemos mandar un a un satélite con otro
tipo de virus
visión a reactivo total
y pueda entonces ver lo que está pasando
con ese satélite y nosotros desde aquí
de la tierra los ingenieros podemos
identificar qué es lo que tiene y
poderlo reparar o hacer una análisis y
si ese satélite tiene manos robóticas y
lo puede reparar con lo que nosotros
estamos mandando desde aquí de la tierra
sería increíble verdad porque obviamente
constan tan lejos no los podemos
alcanzar y si les pasa algo no los
podemos reparar ya ahí se quedó entonces
es importante poder
impulsar esa tecnología que es innovador
y para mí es importante inspirar a las
siguientes generaciones de ingenieros
porque ellos son los que van a resolver
los problemas de este mundo ellos son
los que van a encontrarse con todos los
problemas que están estamos teniendo con
estos que es con este en este mundo que
hay ellos van a ser los que van a tener
la tecnología y los productos que van a
tener la solución a pesar de que
nosotros nos dedicamos a hacer
tecnología para explorar galaxias y
otras cosas es muy importante invertir
en nuestras nuestras generaciones y
guiarlas en este mundo
no sólo para poder que entren con
empresas verdad pero para darle las
manos y para que se puedan superar
porque ellos van a ser el reemplazo de
demi de yo del ingeniero ellos van a ser
los que van a tomar la nueva
van a seguir mis pasos y van a seguir
adelante entonces es importante para mí
poder darles una inspiración y también
ser el representante hasta cierto punto
de las posibilidades que ellos pueden
tener para que no somos todos perfectos
que tenemos problemas que no todos
caminamos el mismo caminito para poder
llegar a donde estamos y que podemos
hacer cosas increíbles y por último les
quiero dar esta fotografía que es
también de ustedes aquí ese círculo que
ustedes ven ahí hay un punto azul que
está ahí es un dar a ese punto azul que
se suspende en en esa en ese espacio es
nuestra tierra esta tierra que está que
está donde están ustedes y en esta
tierra
en este lugar todos los que amamos
verdad han vivido aquí y van a morir
aquí todos sus triunfos y todos sus
fracasos que ustedes van a tener van a
estar aquí verdad y no hay otro lugar en
la galaxia que pueda vivir un ser humano
este es nuestro hogar en ningún otro
lugar y es aquí donde yo les invito a
reflexionar que no dejes que las
circunstancias te definan tu destino tu
definirte a ti mismo y el cambio que
quieres ver en el mundo nuestro mundo
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]